the red-faced demon is an evil entity
who may be as ancient as time itself it
resides in another world another plane
is separate from the land of the living
does this other plane have a name let's
call it
the further it's possible that the demon
came about in the 1700s which is when
historians believe the first modern
Carnival originated in the Caribbean
because Insidious director James Wan has
described the Demon's appearance as
something out of a crazy mystical
Carnival the Tufts of hair protruding
from the side of the head and razor
sharp teeth do bear a resemblance to
another terrifying Carnival entity from
another plane of existence Pennywise
however other demons in the franchise
have the ability to change their
appearance so it's possible that this
demon is much older but redface's
confinement to the further would not
last forever one of the main ideas
expressed in the franchise is the
inherent risk that comes with exploring
the other world I've been to that door
it's not a place for Pure Souls it is it
is very dangerous things come back with
you and I believe that's exactly what
happened when psychic medium Elise
Rainier entered the further in about
2007. I'm guessing the year based on the
fact that insidious chapter 3 takes
place a few years before the first film
ends the main character Quinn has a
T-Mobile Sidekick 3 which came out in
July 2006. Quinn's family isn't doing
well so it makes sense that she'd have
last year's model Quinn ends up getting
stranded in the further by another demon
and Elise has to come out of retirement
to rescue her it seems that all is well
after this but Elise does not
immediately realize what came back with
her she gets home to find her late
husband's vest on the bed and at first
she believes it was his Spirit who
placed it there then she notices a face
in the closet
to learn how this entity became attached
to the Lambert family what the demon is
supposed to represent and how its
presence can still be felt today stick
around to the end of this video this
video is sponsored by Factor
I'm analyzing what most people consider
the main antagonist of the Insidious
franchise in the film he is referred to
as the man with fire on his face but in
the end of credits he's tagged as
lipstick face demon however this seems
to be more of a nickname created by the
filmmakers because of the way that the
special effects makeup was applied the
reason why he's caught the lipstick face
demon is because he literally paints his
face with a red lipstick so many fans
just refer to the character as the
red-faced demon in addition to the
Pennywise similarity that I already
mentioned redface seems to be an
amalgamation of the scariest parts of
many Horrors in cinema the obvious one
that comes to mind is Darth Maul from
Star Wars The Phantom Menace whose
iconic scene takes place at the end of a
hallway of red lights not unlike the
demon in Insidious red face also has
long claw-like hands reminiscent of
Freddy Krueger from A Nightmare on Elm
Street Freddy is known for haunting
characters in their dreams and before
Dalton learns about astral projection
and Insidious he believes the further to
be a dream world the character also
possesses a black body a tale a forked
tongue and fur around his hooved feet
it's giving off similarities to to
traditional depictions of Satan the
further is stated to be a limbo that
exists before a ghost moves on so it's
possible that the red-faced demon is
supposed to be the further equivalent of
the devil the character is played by
Joseph Bashar if that name sounds
familiar it's either because he's also
the composer of the film's score or
because you recognize him from other
roles he's played such as Bathsheba in
The Conjuring or Malthus in the
Annabelle film both of which I've
already covered on Horror history who
would have thought a composer would be
the most frequent actor covered on this
show to understand how his character
became attached to the Lambert family
we've got to take it back to elise's
most personal investigation yet
foreign
in 2010 a few years into elise's
partnership with specs and Tucker of
spectralsightings.com she's called back
to her hometown in New Mexico to deal
with a demon who haunted her all the way
back in her youth it pulls her into the
further but she defeats it with the help
of her mother and nieces little does she
know they are being followed by the
red-faced demon or something to that
effect as they make their way out of the
Dark Realm they take a wrong turn and
end up in the further version of the
Lambert family's attic the further is
not bound by time meaning that wandering
Souls can visit events from past and
possibly the future although we've yet
to see that happen Dalton Lambert is the
son of Josh Lambert who at least helped
many years ago and they see him fall off
of an old ladder but Elise doesn't know
who he is yet and thinks they've gone
the wrong way from Dalton's perspective
in the real world he can't see any of
them but he does hear the crackling
sound emitted by the red-faced demon
foreign
the reason that the red-faced demon has
stayed with Elise for the last few years
is because of her abilities as a medium
although she rarely uses it she has the
ability to astral project she can
project her spirit out of her body and
into the further the Demon's goal is to
possess the bodies of the living most
non-living entities crave life but at
least later explains that this demon
wants to possess a body simply to cause
pain to others when the demon sees
Dalton it realizes that he too has the
ability to astral project and sees him
as an easier Target because of his
naivety as a kid Dalton believes his
astral projection is just a fun dream so
he's not afraid to venture deep into the
further thus leaving his body as an open
vessel for an evil spirit to try to
possess because of this red face sticks
with Dalton and coaxes him further and
further into the further see that's why
they call it bats each demon or major
entity has their own space in the
further behind a red door and these
doors can connect to different locations
and time periods redface puts a door to
his lair right in the Lambert's attic
essentially replacing the connection
between their California home and
Elisa's New Mexico home that used to be
that perhaps because he was curious
about the noise he heard there and
perhaps partially because he's been
banned from the attic in real life he
visits the location in what he thinks is
his dream and goes far enough into the
Demon's Lair to discover this horse
statue which he draws a picture of when
he wakes up Dalton also sees red face at
some point and draws pictures of him as
well in addition to the Red Doors this
picture shows it standing at the
semi-circle shaped window next to the
spinning machine that it uses to sharpen
its claws it's possible that Dalton was
at first intrigued by this brightly
colored new friend and went deeper and
deeper into the further to try to get a
look at him director James Juan and
screenwriter Lee winnell alluded to the
idea that his appearance is supposed to
be inviting to children at first it's
kind of like a clown you know it's his
Twisted way of trying to make himself
look like a good happy person to try and
entice you to him he's the one who's out
there trying to suck in the spirits of
innocent people especially children try
and get them out of their bodies to draw
them out into the further so that he can
then go in and inhabit their body in my
opinion it didn't work he's just
straight up terrifying but this is a
horror movie and that's a good thing the
music he listens to also plays into the
idea that he's trying to entice Dalton
his favorite song is Tiptoe Through the
Tulips by Tiny Tim you can imagine a kid
being drawn in by the silly falsetto
vocals and ukulele strums but once you
get into the Demon's Lair and hear it
echoing through an empty realm of
tortured Souls you start to realize oh
yeah this song is creepy AF in an
interview with the film stage James Wan
refers to it as Serial Killer music it
would not be long before Dalton began
referring to these dreams as nightmares
and he'd eventually find himself in one
nightmare he could not wake up from
food I eat it you eat it some people
even blog it but cooking healthy meals
can be expensive and take a lot of time
the solution is to get Factor not only
is Factor cheaper than takeout but meals
are ready quicker than restaurant
delivery in just two minutes they
deliver the meals right to your door so
you don't even have to think about
making a trip to the store they're
registered dietitians work hand in hand
with their kitchen to ensure that every
meal is made from scratch with a
nutritious ingredients your meal is
delivered fresh never froze into your
door just heat eat and enjoy amp up your
factory order with add-ons like proteins
juices energy bites veggie sides
desserts and more and don't worry Factor
snacks and desserts accommodate those
following plant-based and keto diets
I've been enjoying hellofresh
unsponsored for over a year so when
Factor reached out and I found out that
they're owned by hellofresh I knew that
I had to try it and then ended up being
perfect for me it tastes great and it
saves me time which I guess I'm now
using that time to shoot and edit this
ad read but it will save me time in the
future head to factor75.com or click the
link below and use code cz60 to get 60
off your your first Factor box who else
gives 60 off just use code cz60 to save
[Music]
Josh and Renee Lambert have just moved
into their new home with their three
children when strange things start to
occur in reality I can't tell you if the
Red Face demon is responsible or if it
was just one of the other many ghosts
attracted adult and seeking a human body
to inhabit something moves some of
Renee's books there's a breathing sound
heard in the house which may have just
been a draft a furnace turns on in the
Attic all on its own and the attic door
opens without anyone touching it that
one probably was the demon trying to
lure Dalton up the stairs Renee sheet
music also goes missing and she finds it
in that same attic finally the ladder
breaks under Dalton and although he's
okay at first the next morning he
doesn't wake up in reality the fall is
not what hurt him that night he went too
deep into the Demon's Lair and was
captured and changed to some kind of
demonic Shrine with him trapped in the
further the demon or any of the other
spirits that have shown up at the house
would have an opportunity to take
possession of the vacant vessel three
months go by and Dalton still appears to
be in a coma he's living at home off of
IVs Renee is working downstairs when she
hears something in the baby monitor
the voice says he won't wake up there's
nothing you can do again it isn't clear
if this is redface himself or one of the
other Spirits what is clear is what this
voice wants
the Lambert's other son Foster becomes
afraid of rooming across the hall from
Dalton because he claims that his
brother is walking around at night which
is most likely a result of the demon who
can be invisible in the real world
puppeting his body around the house they
also find red handprints on Dalton
sheets with long pointed fingers Nick
Cave and the Bad Seeds would have had a
field day with this when redface first
discovers the unoccupied body Elise sees
it in her dream foreign
[Music]
handprints manifest themselves on the
window convinced that their house is
haunted the Lambert's move again but the
spirits that haunt the place follow the
scent of Dalton's uninhabited self and
the Paranormal Activity continues in the
new house as Renee is taking the trash
out the evil creature changes her music
to something a little more to its own
liking
[Music]
the grandmother comes to the house and
sees strange things as well one night
she had a dream which was an out-of-body
experience into the further where she
saw the demon in silhouette while
checking on Dalton in his room it told
her that it was a visitor and when she
asked what it wanted it pointed to
Dalton the next day when telling the
story to Josh and Renee redface makes a
more direct appearance
foreign
locks the door shut as it tears through
everything leaving the place in complete
disarray with the comatose boy laying on
the ground when they regain entry having
seen enough they call in Elise specs and
Tucker they bring in something called a
tri-field meter and Tucker picks up the
red-faced Demon's crackling noises
then again outside of Foster's room
and when Elise visits Dalton's room she
hears the noises coming from right above
his bed
being the only one able to see the
Monster she describes it to Specs who
sketches something very similar to
Dalton's drawings and is also really
creepy after seeing it potentially
speaking to Renee on the baby monitor
appearing IRL behind Josh and allowing
the paranormal investigators to make a
sketch I don't think redface fears the
humans even Elise who has the power to
see what it's up to it's certainly
different from James Wan's other demon
hunting franchise The Conjuring where we
see some entities trying to hide
themselves from the Paranormal
investigating protagonists redface has
probably never faced a formidable Foe
and has no reason to be scared of humans
plus Elise is portrayed to be much less
superheroey than Lorraine Warren and
specs and Tucker combined are still
probably less a jack of all trades than
Ed Warren is for these reasons I like
these investigators way more but that's
neither here nor there Elise explains
the nature of Dalton's coma in the now
famous line it's not the house that's
haunted
it's your son she goes on to explain
that many nearby entities can smell the
open vessel that is Dalton's body but
the demon is the only one who is very
close to possessing him the team sets up
cameras around where they'll be
performing a seance and seem to connect
with the boy's Spirit but he stops
talking when the demon notices what he's
up to and he eventually claims that if
the man with fire on his face hears him
he's going to hurt him and not long
after the evil entity hijacks the
communication into rates at least with
obscenities threatening to rip her
innards out and eat the guts that spill
from her for the first time in months
outside of Foster's claims about him
sleepwalking Dalton moves he appears to
sleepwalk over to the group and smack
the table effectively aerating everyone
in this vicinity he also smacks specs
sending him flying across the room into
a wall while it would appear that Dalton
has been possessed to do these things
one of the still frames eventually
reveals that the red-faced demon was
only standing behind the boy essentially
puppeting his body it takes time for an
entity of the further to actually
possess somebody and redface was at the
doorstep but not quite there regardless
elise's retaliation seemed to do the
trick for the time being and the demon
retreated to its Lair to presumably
sharpen up its claws one last time
before making an Ultimate attempt at
taking over Dalton's body an interesting
detail about the layer is the Demon's
collection of marionettes which are
likely symbolic of the way that
red-faced puppeteered Dalton's body
during the Seance it seems it was able
to do this convincingly because it
practiced to become an expert using
these puppets the layer is also
decorated with Gothic Revival
architecture featuring great chandeliers
and candelabras Roman looking statues
everywhere gargoyles a low-lying fog and
a giant mass looking upwards the scene
was filmed in The Herald examiner
building in Downtown Los Angeles one of
the few examples of 100 year old
architecture that still maintains a
Sheen of luxury perfect for this demon
who is both ancient and Powerful among
the world of demons but the demons
netherworldly and manicure is
interrupted when it notices the spirit
of Josh Lambert who is projected into
the further to try to save his son and
the interruption of the further's most
nefarious creature would not be welcome
[Music]
after finding out why his son refers to
this demon as the man with fire in his
face firsthand he's irrigated across the
room by the creature's Screech but the
distraction allows Dalton and now free
from his chains to escape the demon can
be seen charging and knocking Josh down
a second time before he gets to his feet
Scoops up his son and runs for it
leaving the red-faced demon to track
them with its piercing yellow eyes this
battle was not over and its ferocity was
shaking the entire house back in the
real world the Father and Son find
themselves surrounded by wandering
Spirits having called too much attention
to themselves and Josh uses the last of
his energy to get them back to the house
unable to go on he stops to rest and
tells Dalton to go on ahead and return
to his own body but before the boy can
get there he's ambushed by his demonic
captor who is waiting for him in his
room Dalton flees to his parents room
but redface once again teleports through
the further and this time emerging under
the bed to try to drag the child under
but he wiggles free and runs down the
hall red face then unleashes more of his
power by wall crawling out of the room
in the the drywall crumbling with each
step that he takes but he's unable to
recapture Dalton who makes it back to
his physical body closing the door on
any chances of being possessed the only
other available vessel then is Josh who
does get partially possessed by another
entity known as the bride in black
leaving no available landing spot for
the demon with the red phase he can't
even go back to stalking Elise because
she's killed by the bride in black so
her body is no longer of use with this
development redface seems to just give
up on the Lambert family and move on to
a new Target a girl named Allison who
also had the ability to astral project
Allison was in some kind of accident and
had to be resuscitated at the hospital
but While She Was Out She seemingly
ventured into the further and brought
the red face demon in back with her
after helping the Lambert family clear
out their evil spirits a second time
specs and Tucker visit Allison's family
to try to offer assistance with the
least tagging along as a spirit in the
further when Elise tries to elicit a
response from Allison she seems to be as
empty of a shell as Dalton once was and
it's not long before Elise figures out
why
oh my God
Elise recognizes that sound from The
Haunting that resulted in her losing her
own life the battle was not over the
upcoming Insidious fear the dark AKA
chapter 5 will supposedly catch up with
the Lambert family 10 years later as
much as scary ghosts plus scary virus
sounds like a terrifying combination I
am going to be very frustrated if we
don't get a follow-up on this
Cliffhanger however if we do see Darth
Maul's lost cousin again I'll be sure to
update this video make sure you don't
miss that or any of my other Insidious
character analyzes by subscribing to
cz's world for new Horrors every week
bringing that death bell for all
notifications and I will see you in the
next one assuming we both survive